okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of q a about history of Science
and Technology
and I see a number of questions got
saved up here
uh
well let's see
David is asking what are some of the
most prominent developments in 20th
century history of software design
well first point to make is there wasn't
any software before the 20th century the
first software that existed was really
in the 1950s I would say
um
so I mean to kind of go through a little
bit of the history that the whole idea
that you could make a universal computer
that is a fixed piece of Hardware that
you merely had to put different programs
into to get it to do different things
that was something that arose kind of
out of ideas and Mathematics
mathematical logic and so on with people
like Alan Turing in 1936 and then uh and
then sort of a that was a that was a
theoretical Branch then there was a
practical branch that
came from going from electromechanical
calculators to electronic computers and
that happened in the mid-1940s with
things like eniac and so on in the
original instant instantiation of
computers electronic computers there was
the notion of the so-called stored
program computer the computer where you
could have uh the the the data that the
computer was operating on like the
numbers that it was doing calculations
with and so on were stored just as the
program that specified how to do those
computations when you should add when
you should multiply when you should
Branch into this uh conditional
Thing versus another all of that was
being stored in the same kind of a way
that the um uh the the actual data about
numbers and so on was being stored and
that happened in the 1940s and so on
um and the Very earliest software so to
speak speak was some
was very very low level I mean it really
just said there's this uh this switch
that's going to be uh you know uh
operated in this way on this computer
switch number such and such is going to
be operated this way and then this one
to this way and so on if you look at the
coding sheets that existed that
specified what programs should be stored
in these very early computers they're
extremely primitive
um I think uh well for example the um
um
let's see there was a computer so there
were different computers there were
computers in the US the eniac
um and then the edvac and a series of
other computers in England there were
computers called the the ace
um and so on uh one computer where I
happened to have looked at a little bit
as the uh in Manchester there was an ace
computer that Alan Turing was involved
with
um he wasn't I think very happy at the
fact that people didn't listen to what
he had to say about about how one should
do quote software design and so on
um but anyway uh I did once look at his
coding sheets from that computer and
um it is uh all kinds of crazy weird
things there because there were things
like specifying uh operations and so on
and there was a question of well in the
end they're going to be specified in
terms of binary bits but one was you
know he was trying to sort of write them
out in an efficient way and so he
started using all the different
characters on a tele type with two
represent those sequences of binary bits
I mean I think he was using basically
base 32
writing out numbers in base 32 which
means you've got to have you know uh 22
things beyond the ordinary digits and
they were specified with letters and so
on and if you look at his coding sheets
they're utterly obscure
so
one thing that was an early sort of
Discovery in software was the idea of
subroutines the idea of sub functions
when John Von Neumann was kind of
writing out sort of reports about kind
of what operations you might want to do
on a computer he was doing that based on
sort of his understanding of mathematics
and his understanding of logic and one
of the things that he famously said was
I think he said nobody will ever want to
write a program that's more than 400
lines long okay so it turns out
obviously to be completely false there
are there are programs that are tens of
millions of lines long even we've
created such programs and that's what
our technology stack is as a as a
probably by now 100 million line program
or something
um the uh you know why was John Von
Neumann so wrong
well the answer is he didn't have the
idea of kind of subroutines he thought
when you wrote out a program it was
everything that was going to be done was
going to be right there in the in the
program you wrote out it's kind of like
writing out a proof in mathematics where
sort of everything is there right in the
proof and you're not referring to other
theorems along the way and the proof
which then have their own separate
proofs he seems to have kind of missed
that idea but that was an early kind of
software idea was the idea that you
could have functions that are or
subroutines that are separately executed
that where you define that you write the
code for that you can test that
separately you can think about it
separately it is sort of a cognitive
unit that's separate from the rest of
the program
now I think in terms of the the calling
of subroutines
um that took a little bit of Technology
development to see how that would work
because when you when you're running a
program and then you call a subroutine
you want to be able to uh start doing
things in the subroutine and then come
back from the subroutine and be back in
the state ready to execute the next
instruction in the main program and that
required the invention of the idea of a
stack
um and I'm not completely sure when
Stacks were first first done on
computers but that was for for example
in the way that you call a subroutine
and the way that you allocate memory for
the local variables of the subroutine
that was not clean at least until the C
programming language came along in the
um uh in the 1970s
um in things like Fortran
um that's a much Messier Story how how
you really how allocate space on the
stack and for example Fortran didn't
have the possibility of recursively
calling functions you could if a
function couldn't call itself that was
just not allowed by the compiler in
early versions of Fortran I think
because this mechanism of sort of having
this stack where you could push things
on the stack and keep doing that over
and over again didn't really exist so I
think I would say one of the first
things that was realized in kind of sort
of the development of software well
let's go through some of them I mean one
was you can not just refer to the
literal operations of the machine the
literal you know move the switch from
here to there
um that was something where you made
things it's really been a trend of
making things sort of more symbolic in
some sense of symbolic so for example
you could say well uh we're going to
store these numbers in register 11. okay
and we specifically say 11. and every
everywhere we reference reference that
number which might represent the length
of some thing and somewhat a Time
variable or something like this now
let's say a length variable
um you always say it's in register 11.
well then people had the idea of
variables where you say it's a variable
it's called L and we always associate L
with register 11. but we can write in
our programs we can just write L and
that's an easier thing for us to
remember than remembering oh the length
is stored in register 11.
um so
there's uh uh sort of that was that was
another piece of progress was the idea
of having sort of variables to represent
lumps of memory then the idea of having
names to represent lumps of program
which was kind of the idea of
subroutines that you could name this
lump of code and name it with the name
of that subroutine the name of that
function
and just refer to it that way so I
suppose one of the early ideas was sort
of this notion of give names to things
whether it's variables where the lumps
of memory or whether it's
um uh pieces of of um uh pieces of code
um I think then
well let's see other kinds of important
developments in terms of of software
um the uh I mean things like
well okay we can look at it in terms of
the actual systems that were built
um
you know there was the question of what
can you represent in software what can
you actually represent on a computer the
earliest idea was let's let's it's sort
of a mathematics based idea let's
represent numbers let's represent
logical variables true false and things
like that then there was the idea what
about strings what about character
strings and that was where in Fortran
for example you would have these
Hollerith uh the hollow Earth was that
was someone Hollerith was a person who
was an early IBM
um who um uh was responsible for
tabulating machines for the Census
Bureau in the early 1900s and his name
kind of got attached to this idea that
sort of arose in the Fortran IBM world
of um of of having not the only place
that arose actually but but being able
to represent character strings as things
that computers could deal with and that
led to things like ASCII and well
earlier episode deck
um this way of of saying will represent
an a by the number 65 or whatever else
it is so this this mapping of of um uh
of character strings to numbers actually
I suppose there's probably a trend a few
Trends here I mean one trend is uh sort
of the naming of things being able to
refer to things by names that sort of uh
relate to the kinds of things that we
humans would talk about as opposed to
just saying it's it's the the thing that
numbers such and register numbers such
and such that's one thing the other
thing is taking more things in the world
and sort of making them uh computational
by saying oh we can take character
strings and and represent them in terms
of bits we can take logic represented in
terms of bits we can take numbers
represented in terms of bits and so on
there were other things even even with
numbers there were
um questions about how do you represent
numbers and the notion of floating Point
numbers
um numbers were so so one thing you
could do is just say I've got this
collection of bits and the first few
bits represent the you know the the ones
column the tens column the hundreds
column of the number the one-tenths
column the 100th num column Etc that's a
fixed Point number then there's the
notion of a floating Point number where
you say these bits represent the
mantissa of the number and then it's
times 10 to the power or times two to
the power such and such a thing you can
you can float the decimal points around
wherever you want and that was an idea
when that come in probably the 50s was
when that um when that was introduced
but it then got kind of uh this IEEE
floating Point standard got introduced
I'm not a big fan of that I think it's
led to just all kinds of crazy problems
um that because it doesn't it doesn't
tag the Precision of a number it just
says here's a number but it's got this
number of bits just deal with them how
you will without saying oh well actually
most of these bits are nonsense
so in any case the the
um
uh in terms of the development of kind
of ideas in
um uh in in kind of programs
um there were some things that were
actually very early ideas but they
didn't catch on there were ideas that
had come from combinators that came into
lisp in and that was defined at least
theoretically in the late 1950s
um ideas about pure functions Anonymous
functions Lambda functions whatever you
call them functions where instead of
saying we've got a function f of x and
that's equal to x squared or something
like you would in sort of traditional
math you can have a Lambda function
where you say it's just this pure
function it's just the F there's no f of
x it's just the F and you can carry
around that function on its own and
apply it to things that was an idea that
was actually a rose in in well actually
Rose in the 1920s with Sean Finkel and
combinators but it was sort of first
sort of made into something like a a
software Thing by a John McCarthy in the
late 1950s and the specification of lisp
it finally became something that was
widely used I mean I why I started using
it in SMP in 1979 it's been used in
modern language since the beginning in
um it has finally become fairly popular
um across lots of different
um lots of different languages and so on
this idea if you just pick up a function
and think about it on its own and you
can you can operate with functions on
their own
um I would say that the okay what was
some other Big Ideas another another big
idea uh in the very early days just as
one had said
um that uh
uh variables representing pieces of
memory were named so were
um uh so uh so were functions Blobs of
code that could execute another thing
that got named another thing got
specified were go-to's you'd have a
bunch of code and that would be this
operation this operations operation this
operation and so on and you would be
able to say Okay I want to I'm I'm
running one instruction then the next
then the next then the next and then
it's go to some other place and you
could label the go to
turns out that was a very ugly way to
program turns out it was very hard to
tell what was going on it turns out that
that wasn't a very modular approach to
programming the whole idea that you
should be able to take programs apart
and think about them in a modular way is
an idea that I would say started to gain
serious traction probably only in the
1980s although it was certainly a known
idea in the 1970s but it wasn't an idea
that people really focused on
um okay so there were there are many
kinds of steps and kind of um other
kinds of things that were sort of an
early early ideas in in software were
arrays the idea that
um instead of just having an individual
number you could have an array of
numbers you can have you know for
example a one-dimensional array or a
two-dimensional array
um and that you can do operations
perhaps on the whole array at a time APL
for example in its original
specification at the beginning of the
60s was a language very much oriented
towards specifying just add one to the
whole array you don't have to specify
separately okay make a loop do add a 1
to the first element second elements and
so on that's obviously an idea that in
more from language we uh take seriously
it's it's an idea that is very natural
for people
um the only time it isn't natural is
when they've been taught oh computers
just do one thing at a time you have to
make a loop to do this then this then
this and there's a certain amount of
unlearning that has to be done when
people say no you don't have to do that
that and more from language for example
you just add one to the to the to the
list and it'll add add one to every
element and so on but that was that was
another idea was the idea of arrays
um another idea
which was kind of a a low level idea was
the idea of pointers which was sort of
popularized by c
um and that was the idea of uh well so
so one of the issues had been when you
have a subroutine for example and you
are going to give data to the subroutine
how do you give it that data do you say
when you call the subroutine are you
taking the values of certain variables X
and Y and so on and just feeding those
values to the subroutine or are you
instead taking the names X and Y and
telling the subroutine go look for the
data in the place that corresponds to
the name X the name Y and so on in
Fortran there's this idea of of uh call
by name which is which says you you at
least nearly four times I don't actually
know how it's evolved today
um but uh you know you basically just
say what you want subroutine is the
thing that's called X
so you can go and go and find that as
opposed to giving it the value that's
part of the reason that recursion wasn't
possible is because the thing that was
called x one time wouldn't be the thing
that was called X the next time that
same function was called but so this
idea of just call by value that was an
idea that was sort of became kind of the
default
um in in later programming languages but
then there's another thing which is uh
call by reference where you're basically
saying instead of the X I want to refer
to X by the place in memory where X is
stored so that's that's the the idea of
getting the address of X I should
explain that sort of a big idea that had
risen in the late
1950s was the idea of compilers where
you would take a higher level language a
language that was more sort of human
friendly
um and uh and make it um
uh and then and then automatically turn
it into something which was operating at
the machine code level originally
Fortran was the the formula translation
language where the idea was to write
something that kind of looked like math
um it wasn't that much like math but
somewhat like math and translated into
the machine code so that the machine
could execute it
uh you know there have been other sort
of ideas
um I would say that the um uh
um an idea that was uh popular in the
mid-1980s with the whole object-oriented
idea
um that was particularly relevant
um when you're building user interfaces
and when you want to say I've got a
window and it has all these various
different things that can be done to it
I've got another window and it can have
things done to it and this idea of
organizing programs so that you would
organize it in terms of objects and
methods and so on uh as an approach to
organizing programs that particularly
good if you're building things like user
interfaces it is not as general as it
you might think it would be
um but it's useful for those purposes at
least and and by the way a big Trend
coming into the 1980s and um uh and so
on was bigger programs how do you deal
with organizing bigger programs what are
some Concepts in in working on bigger
programs in a sense there was a merger
there between the technical side of how
do you organize programs and the
management side of how do you organize
teams working on programs and then there
were the between
um
um and I think that that um uh that was
kind of a um
um and that you know things like the
object-oriented approach
um were sort of combination in a sense
ways of thinking about management people
people talked a lot about in the 80s uh
talked a lot about software components
and being able to plug one piece of
software into another piece of software
and so on
um that kind of turned I suppose into
the idea of libraries and things like
that
um I think there are a couple of Big
Ideas which which I've been much
involved in which are
um uh so one is the idea of functional
programming the idea that you think of
things in terms of functions and
everything that happens in a piece of
code is just applying functions to
things that's not that's an idea that
that I've made a lot of use of it's
certainly not my idea so to speak
um the uh uh what's ended up happening
is I think it's a very useful organizing
idea of just say how do you make a
function out of that how do you do some
how do you make something where you can
sort of describe what you feed into that
piece of computation and what comes out
of that piece of computation how do you
describe those things and and then the
sort of packaging that piece of
computation in this thing that is a
self-contained function it doesn't have
tentacles hanging out going all up to
sorts of other places it's this
self-contained thing that's an important
idea and sort of how you think about
things computationally but then there's
the idea of sort of just working with
the disembodied functions and building
up kind of higher level functions doing
things like you know in the simple case
mapping a fun over a list or another
thing would be you know composing
functions together doing things that
where functions are operating on
functions to create kind of uh higher
level functionality so that's another
idea another idea I've been deeply
involved in myself is is the idea of
symbolic programming uh the idea that uh
it's kind of the question of how do you
represent things in the world for a
computer and sort of uh in the end it's
got to be represented in terms of bits
but that's far away from the way that
humans should think about it and you
know if you're representing a city how
do you do that for a computer and if
you're representing an image how do you
do that for a computer and being able to
kind of have this notion of things being
represented symbolically where they
don't have to have sort of values that
where the computer can explicitly see or
I can turn that into a bunch of where
where when you run the program it's like
turning it into uh something like
numbers or strings or something where
you can immediately imagine I know how
the computer is going to represent that
it's something where you can maintain
the thing in a symbolic form that that
we can interpret in terms of the real
world but which we can't necessarily
readily interpret in terms of the way
it's represented in bits on the computer
and so sort of a version of that is you
have an X what does The X mean well
often you'd say well X has to be
something what does that mean b
something it might mean it's got to be a
number that you can represent in terms
of a collection of bits it's got to be a
string you know how to represent that in
terms of a collection of bits but in a
symbolic language like well if language
for example X can just stand for itself
you can just manipulate X on its own
just as X and you might use it for
algebra you might use it to represent
something and once you have that idea of
symbolic things and once you have the
idea of functional programming as well
you can represent things with symbolic
heads for functions so you just have an
f of x or it might be um something that
says I don't know city of whatever and
that head of this thing is symbolic it's
both handling things at a functional
level and dealing with things
symbolically and the thing which has
been sort of a surprise to me I suppose
is this idea that you can think about uh
programs and think about representing
things computationally by just building
up these symbolic Expressions just
building up functions with symbolic
heads applied to arguments that might be
symbolic and have other functions with
symbolic heads and so on that you can
use that to represent all kinds of
things in the world in fact kind of
everything in the world it seems
you can use that to represent things you
might deal with on a computer like a
user interface like a collection of
programs running like
um all kinds of things like like a
program itself
um that has been a very powerful idea
that certainly in my uh efforts over the
last 40 something years
um that's been sort of a guiding
principle is represent everything in
terms of symbolic expressions
uh important idea not widely understood
even now 40 years later
um another big idea in in my life of
dealing with these kinds of things is
the idea of transformation rules on
symbolic Expressions the idea that you
can represent what computers the part of
what computers do that we humans find
useful in terms of saying you've got a
symbolic expression and it's more or
less like this but there's some pieces
we haven't yet specified uh they you're
defining your function to be something
that says you're defining things to be
saying whenever you see a symbolic
expression like this it gets transformed
into one that's like that
that idea which is ultimately a very
simple idea turns out to be super
powerful and it's the idea that all of
awesome language is based on it's kind
of the idea that that I've been pursuing
for the last 40 what is it 44 years now
and um uh
I think the um and by the way ironically
enough
a version of that idea is exactly the
idea that is at the foundation of our
physics project and our current
understanding of fundamental physics I I
did not see that coming at all I the
fact that this transformation rules for
symbolic Expressions thing was something
that I had built as a matter of
technology for constructing
computational languages was sort of a
completely separate Branch from my
thinking about how should one think
about sort of the computations that
happen at the fundamental level in the
universe the fact that those end up
being the same as one of those personal
ironies I suppose that I certainly
didn't see coming
well I'm sure I'm forgetting a lot of
things about sort of the the evolution
of software I mean I suppose okay
another thing I might say that sort of
in my own uh area is sort of there's
what do you take for granted when you
walk up to a computer you know is it the
raw Hardware the first computer I used
all you had on the computer was the raw
hardware and a few initial instructions
that were burnt in to
um the uh at location 8181 on the
computer you started you pressed a
button to say jump to uh location 8181
and it had these initial instructions
that were actually implemented with
transistors and so on in the computer
that and that was the only thing that
was sort of intrinsic to the computer
later on there were operating systems
that sort of came with computers or that
you came to expect to use on a computer
than languages that you came to expect
then later on uh things like networking
user interfaces those kinds of things
the thing that has been sort of my big
push for the last I don't know 20
something years has been been this idea
of computational knowledge as a thing to
take for granted when you kind of just
walk up to a computer that it is the
case that you expect that your computer
is just going to immediately know about
um kind of uh things about the world in
computational form things about
algorithms and so on that you're going
to be able to talk about cities or
distances between them on the earth or
things about algorithms and so on and
that your computer is just intrinsically
going to have that stuff built into it
and that's what we've been trying to
achieve over all these years with wolf
and language I mentioned one other thing
in the development of software so I've
talked about how one of the things that
happened starting in the 80s I suppose
was people started to think about how
are we going to organize these big
software systems in terms of the way
that the code was organized in terms of
the way the code is managed in terms of
source code control in terms of the way
teams work on things in terms of the way
the the code the things are specified
and so on and they're these you know the
waterfall approach the agile approach
that you know all these kinds of things
are different management schemes for
thinking about how do you how do you
develop a piece of code because in a
sense there's in the end what you need
is something where you are saying this
piece of code is going to do something
that's useful to people well what's the
thing you want it to do and then how do
you build the code so that it is as
maintainable as possible has uh
Etc et cetera et cetera as extensible as
possible and so on I think the one
discipline so to speak that people still
have not understood is incredibly
important is kind of the whole idea of
language design functional design of
software people this this thing that
I've spent a huge amount of time on and
uh you know I live stream some of my
efforts in this um regularly I just did
a live stream just before this actually
um that this idea of how do you design
uh the way that a software system should
look at the level of functions at the
level of a language and so on and to me
this is the most concentrated form of
kind of uh human understanding that I
know of it's it's something where you
are trying to get ultimate sort of
operational understanding of different
areas you're trying to make things
you're trying to boil things down to the
point where there are uh you know you're
getting the essential features and you
want to do that in a way that's very
consistent and coherent so that and this
is the sort of big thing of wolfen
language so that all these different
pieces whether you're doing image
processing or machine learning or audio
processing or whether you're doing all
these different things they all fit
together they all are consistent and the
things that apply to one of them apply
to others and so on and that process of
doing language design which is really a
process of going from the complicated
requirements that people have down to
the the essence The Primitives to see
how things fit together that to me is a
is is a very a very important and very
high leverage intellectual activity and
very difficult one that uh well I mean I
I you know I enjoy doing it I think it's
a deeply deeply underappreciated
activity I mean eventually people will
realize that that's kind of one of this
sort of the pivotal intellectual
activities that was the determining
factor of whether people could actually
think in a language whether people could
actually build a big tower of
functionality and so on or not and
that's that's why I spend so much time
on this because I think it is this sort
of pivotal piece of kind of this pivotal
very essential core kind of intellectual
activity and uh you know we've slowly
diffused the knowledge of kind of how to
do language design but that's a thing
that um has happened extremely slowly I
would say
um but it's something where where uh you
know that that's something which I think
will be seen eventually as as one of the
sort of pivotal realization that that
was an important thing sort of the the
and it's very much it becomes very much
more realistic when you have ideas like
symbolic programming and transmissions
on symbolic expressions and so on that
it's much more you have much better sort
of raw material to operate with in terms
of language design when you have those
kinds of ideas because this kind of
symbolic idea means that for example you
can take programs apart into arbitrarily
small pieces because at every stage the
things the programming is operating on
are just symbolic Expressions you can
just pick one up do something with it
it's not oh it's some data structure
embedded inside the computer we can't it
should pick it up and do things we have
to write other code to be able to read
in write out that that data structure
all right very long answer to that
um uh
let's see
um
okay
oh my gosh lots of interesting questions
here
um
all right I'm gonna take one from Baines
here saying I watched recent NASA rocket
launch and wonder what's new in the past
60 years in terms of launching Rockets
um you know it's surprising that you
know the principles are very much the
same even the designs I gather are are
rather the same I mean I think when uh
you know early even SpaceX for example
you know licensed I I think um you know
early Russian designs
um that um you know I'm sure they've
been developed since then but you know
one question is why is it hard to make a
rocket and uh you know first point is
you're pushing it from the back and it's
got to go up straight and so that was a
thing people like Goddard in the 1920s I
guess
um started figuring out how do you make
a control system where you can actually
have the thing have the the rocket
nozzle
um sort of be be controlled so that when
you push it from the bottom it doesn't
just fall over
that was the first step
um that problem's been solved you know
it's why when you if you watch a launch
from um an Apollo launch I don't know
whether they do this still it always
used to be the case you know I when I
was a kid I watched the you know the
Apollo you know launchers and one of the
notable features on the big Saturn V
rocket they would have these black
stripes and white stripes painted on it
and I was like why do they do that and I
figured out oh because if you're taking
a you know if you're looking at the
video If you're looking at this at this
thing you can tell if it's if it's
turning you can tell if the thing is
rotating around if it's got big black
and white stripes otherwise it's just a
big silver a white rocket or something
and you can't tell whether it's twisting
but
in any case I think you know the big
thing is that uh you know rocketry is
about burning stuff and it's about
keeping materials at the point where
they are undergoing complicated phase
Transitions and you end up with this
amazingly complicated sort of set of
pipes and tubes and valves and so on and
combustion Chambers and all this in
order to deal with the the sort of nasty
detailed properties of materials right
at the point where they're combusting
and I gather what usually limits Rockets
is the uh how how much the the turbo
pump that's just pumping uh Fuel and the
oxidant of it if it has that into into
the combustion chamber you just got to
do that faster faster faster
so I don't know what's what's what's I
mean I would have thought that there
were
things that have been made possible by
modern sensor technology that weren't
there before and I know certainly in
terms of the sort of early warning of if
something is going wrong there is a
bunch more that's been done there but I
don't think that the fundamental design
of you know how you make a combustion
chamber and things like that I don't
think that's changed very much and I
don't think that the um I think sort of
the the flight controller that means
that you push it from the bottom and it
keeps on going up
um you know I think those principles are
certainly transitioned to being
electronic rather than mechanical as
they were originally but I don't think
that's changed that much either I think
you know when you look at um it's a
little bit shocking that the design of
you know that you see for the um uh
uh you know the the outer shape of of
some rocket is the same well the reason
it's the same is because it's a good
shape for Hypersonic flow and that
hasn't changed now you know is there
some design is there some super clever
design which like for airplanes you know
airplanes had straight wings and then uh
got figured out you put these winglets
at the end that help with transonic flow
and then then winglets became kind of a
designer feature of airplanes and
everybody wanted winglets because they
look cool
um but uh uh you know there are details
like that that get figured out and
different Wing shapes and so on
um and I suspect some of those kinds of
things have been done for Rockets as
well
um and and I would think also that
materials I mean the the world of you
know the tiles on the shuttle that's
been that's been upgraded a lot but you
don't immediately get to see that and
also I think in terms of the actual
controls I mean in you know inside the
um uh all of that stuff is as
dramatically different than it was
before but I think in terms of sort of
the outer shell and the basic ideas I I
think that they're fairly similar
um and uh you know you might say the
same thing about airplanes I mean what's
what's changed you know since there have
been jet planes you know what quotes
really changed and the answer is a lot
of things on the inside about carbon
fiber and you know and Composites and
things like this different kinds of
materials
um and you know if you look at the
detailed patterns of of uh you know a
lot of studies of of from uh
computational fluid dynamics and so on
that have allowed optimization of the
shapes of planes and and things like
this but you know the big picture I
guess has not changed very much in that
case either even though in that case
also tremendous changes in the avionics
the control systems the computerization
the kind of sensors
um all those kinds of things
let's see
uh
let me see
um
Oh Boy Aaron is asking a question I
don't know the answer to but I'm
wondering about is why did American
English develop common words for every
third or magnitude like million billion
trillion other languages seem to have
different words like lack for example in
Hindi
um thought like was ten thousand it's
like a hundred thousand I'm not sure but
this question about the modifiers that
exist in different languages to
represent kind of uh different orders of
magnitude when I was a kid billion in
British English meant million million
which is trillion American English super
confusing
um because
in in the US it
um it you know this idea of going up by
threes
um was was the thing that came in I I
don't know
um I mean I don't know the history of um
uh the kind of the the terms billion and
trillion and quadrillion and so on
um I I think uh the um I mean I kind of
wonder what was the first domain in
which uh well Millions were no doubt
people had millions of dollars they
didn't have billions of dollars that
didn't become a thing until much more
recent times
um and uh so you know I don't actually
know where where those words first came
into use
um and um I'm kind of thinking that uh
you know the things that were referred
to were million million and then
somebody said no no let's just call that
a billion
um and that was you know the the British
English version of million million
um and then um uh uh and then that
evolved into you know and evolved
differently and I don't know exactly
when
um in in the US so I'm afraid I don't
know the answer to that
uh
let's see
um
this is commenting here remember a
comment from an old programmer saying
the first time they saw a screen used
with a computer was in the movie 2001.
certainly true for me
um I mean I saw that that movie came out
in 1968 when I was eight years old
um and uh
um
it's the first movie I ever saw in a
movie theater that as a piece of
personal trivia
um and um and in fact I I am
I I wrote about this actually in in 2008
2018 when the 50th anniversary of of
2001 it was uh uh it's a movie that um
had uh
uh yes it had screens it had um uh which
were of course made in a purely movie
kind of way
um it wasn't um but but computers back
in those days I mean I first saw a
computer a little bit after that time
actually and it was a it was a Mainframe
computer so you couldn't actually get to
the computer it was behind you know sort
of uh armored uh kind of a very very
sequestered uh very um high priest type
um uh setup with I don't remember
whether people actually had white coats
but they might have done around the
computer and um you know the only thing
you got from the computer was a printout
put in a wooden pigeonhole
um and or and you would feed in a card
deck that you had made separately so so
that was that was the first level of
interaction the the original thing uh at
least in British English I'm not
completely sure about American English
um gosh this is a sign of me having
moved from one country to another other
a certain time the early name for a um a
display for a computer at least in
British English was a vdu visual display
unit
um and there those they I first oh gosh
when did I first see one of those
probably
1973 and 1974 and and those first were
used in various kinds of transaction
processing systems I think I mean I
think like uh people doing Airline
reservations were starting to use those
and so on
um as a thing that was by by 1976
975 1976 they were everywhere but those
were those were displays that were
character at a time displays and so they
would have uh you know a typical
technology was they would have a CRT a
cathode ray tube they'd have an electron
beam and there would be a an actual
piece of metal that would have
characters carved out of it and the
Electron Beam would be sent through the
the a-shaped hole in the piece of metal
and then to the screen and and then it
would produce an A and as as the thing
scanned across it would be with an
electric field it would be moving the
Electron Beam
um to to go through the you know the C
uh place in that in that um piece of
metal and then to the right place on the
screen and that was kind of the
technology uh you know early computer
terminals that was the technology they
used it was purely uh worked that way
there was a there was a different
technology which came from oscilloscopes
and oscilloscopes you know you just put
a voltage on and you can make that spot
go anywhere you want and so there's a
technology of storage Scopes uh
oscilloscopes where I think first of all
the actual phosphor was something that
would continue to glow when the dots had
moved on so to speak and so tectronics
was a company famous for for making
these storage Scopes where you would
make graphics by just having that dot
you would control where that dot went
and sort of the X Y plane and you would
sort of paint on on there and the
phosphor would kind of maintain where
the uh where that dot had gone and so
that way you could build up graphics and
then you could print from that and it
was typically some kind of thermal
printing process where you could get
sort of the output that way and that was
sort of the early way to do Graphics
along with pen plotters where you were
doing the same kind of thing as
specifying the dot with X Y you were
specifying the position of the pen where
it would just have these two uh two sort
of um uh you know things with two
Runners with belts and so on where
you're moving the pen in the X Direction
the y direction to draw your your
picture or whatever and that was that
was kind of that early technology the
first place where the big innovation
came in the beginning of the 80s was
bitmap displays
um that was I probably first saw a
bitmap display when I visited Xerox Park
in probably
1979 maybe
um I think I also saw those at um uh
visited IBM research maybe a year or two
later
um but that was a place where you would
have um
the idea was you have this display
that's made of lots of pixels a million
pixels or whatever and you would have a
place in the memory of the computer
where you would assemble a pattern of
bits that were corresponding to what you
wanted the pixels on the display to look
like and you know in the early Xerox
Altos uh it was very much you know Xerox
was a company that was involved with
dealing with photocopying onto paper and
sort of the eight and a half by 11 sheet
of paper type metaphor and the alto had
the screen that was most screens had
been as they are today were kind of
wider than they are tall the alto was
taller than it was wide like a piece of
paper and also had the Innovation that
it had black print on a white background
whereas all of the CRT type things the
the screen was basically black except
where the where the Electron Beam had
had painted on the phosphorus and and
then it was green or whatever and I find
it very ironic that for me you know the
black on white was kind of the great
innovation of the early 80s of when
computers became more kind of uh
familiar and more kind of like printing
on paper and the idea of you know the
green on black was like the ancient
stuff that uh you know was was all
determined by the the the the physics of
cathode ray tubes and things like this
and I find it ironic that today with
kind of dark mode and so on people are
like wow we can have uh you know uh
light
um light type on a black background and
I'm like that was that was how it used
to be in the in the ancient world
um when you know when that was what was
constrained by the physics and
electrical engineering what was going on
you know uh now we can do uh other kinds
of things I just find it ironic but
that's the way that that developed but
um uh yeah I think I think the um
the way that um sort of the bitmap
display was uh really well the Xerox uh
uh kind of office of the future type
thing didn't really as such catch on but
those ideas got transported to you know
the mac and got transported to things
like the sun workstation and so on and
uh you know gave us gave us kind of
computers as they are today
um
all right let's see
William is asking why is chat GPT
blowing up now when gpt3 was known in
2020 and gpt2 in 2019.
because it's much better
if you try and do you know what chat GPT
is fundamentally doing is going from a
textual prompt and it's saying how would
that continue what's the sort of average
way that would continue based on
everything you've seen by crawling the
web and so on
and if you try those things in gpt2 gpt3
they don't work that well it doesn't
make the interesting story it doesn't
make the the thing that really is going
to make you say wow
I don't know exactly what it is and I'm
not sure anybody really completely knows
exactly what it is that's made that jump
happen I think it's partly the
reinforcement learning training where
once taken actual humans and said okay
generate a bunch of essays now say which
ones look really like essays and which
ones look kind of cruddy and miss the
point and one's kind of given that
feedback I think it's also a certain
amount of tuning of how much Randomness
is there and the way those continuations
work it's also additional training
material that it makes a difference that
you've trained it on you know however
many billions of pages as opposed to
only hundreds of millions of pages those
things make a difference but I don't
think we know why that transition well
as an operational matter it's partly the
reinforcement training that's definitely
had an effect it's also just good
engineering done by the folks at open AI
to provide something that has a form
factor that uh you know that just you
know has been structured so that it can
produce essays poems whatever else which
I think more a piece of engineering than
it is the raw language model of the
neural net and so on but yes it's it's a
I mean you know the reason it's it's
blowing up is because it's well
engineered well presented and it
actually works and uh you know and and
these previous things were just not that
interesting I mean I tried them and it's
like yeah this is cool and you know I
mean we've had in Northern language
we've had a
um a sequence predict function which
uses sort of the the progressively
better technology for like predicting
textual sequences in English and it's
not particularly useful
um now it has become so I mean there
were always little precursors of this in
some of the systems that were used for
grammar checking things like this but
but um this is a real real leap and I
think it's telling us something about
sort of how brains work
and and what level of sophistication we
should be expecting in the language
production and brains you'll have more
to say about that sometime soon
um
okay there's a question here about um
how much do I think from spare parts
how much do you think real science and
technology is shaped by ideas from
science fiction
you know more than rather a lot I think
surprisingly much
maybe only by science fiction that
becomes popular maybe more by movies
than by written science fiction I think
that sort of
movies tend to provide a useful kind of
cultural sort of reference point
for kind of what are we trying to build
oh we're trying to build the Star Trek
computer what are we trying to build
we're trying to build a flip phone
that's like the Star Trek Communicator
um you know these are these are kind of
reference points and sometimes
I mean it is interesting the extent to
which one can imagine what will be
possible and then uh you know eventually
the technology gets to the point where
one can do it now you know is that going
to be possible for everything is it
going to be possible for let's say
cryonics and human hibernation is going
to be possible for faster than light
travel is it going to be possible for I
don't know what um uh various kinds of
well it depends what what pick your
movie so to speak what the different
Technologies are
um I think some of them will probably
run into kind of well it won't be done
that way that's a kind of physical
constraint but you know you see these
things where you can imagine it I mean
the idea of a a sort of a book like
object that was electronic that's an
easy idea I'll give you an example of
how this plays out you know back in 1987
um I was uh
uh playing Professor
um at University of Illinois then
um and uh I just started this Research
Center uh I've gone there to start this
Research Center about um complexity and
such like but anyway there was a Apple
computer as it was called then
um had this competition for students to
design a personal computer of the year
2000 and so it was a rather nice
enterprising group of students at
University of Illinois who came to me
and said will you be uh they needed a
you know faculty advisor
um to um
with those projects I said sure
um sounds interesting and so you know we
came up with what the personal computer
of the year 2000 would be like
and um I have to say I kind of avoided
talking too much about software because
I was actually working on software and I
didn't want some complicated
entanglement about
um about that but mostly concentrated on
hardware and as many people pointed out
the thing that we predicted back in 1987
was extremely close to an iPad
um and although the iPad didn't come out
for another you know decade after that
um you know it was like it's a small
thing with a certain form factor as a
screen it's a touch screen it has this
networking it has various attributes
about how that works
Etc et cetera et cetera in a sense those
were inexible predictions I wasn't very
impressed with myself so to speak that
we could come up with those predictions
um that they were they were kind of like
well you see which way things are going
that's going to happen as I've said many
times one of the things that at least I
find much more difficult I think other
people too is you make a prediction
about what will be possible and you'll
write about what's possible you can't
easily predict the time frame over which
which it happens and sometimes things
happen like you know take chat GPT for
example uh I must say I'm I'm surprised
at how comparatively easily we've gotten
over this threshold and we've got to the
point we've got to now but that
something like this would eventually
happen yeah you know that's that's
unquestionably the case that it would
happen suddenly is interesting
um and that it would happen in 2023 you
know 2022 2023 was not something I could
have readily predicted even even seeing
you know even given that I've been
following you know gpt2 gpt3 I couldn't
have told you and then in another year
boom we're going to get to the point
where this is really interesting I
couldn't have said that I'm not sure
anybody else could including the people
working on these projects I think nobody
knew I think it's telling us something
scientifically important but I think
it's it's a surprise
um and I think uh
um yeah anyway so I mean I I think in
terms of of it's interesting to see what
in science fiction hasn't come to
reality I mean people always talk about
when people talk about gestural
interfaces you know being able to move
your hands around to make things happen
they always mention Minority Report
which had a nice rendition of kind of
gesture-based um uh you know interfaces
now of course there is some
gesture-based interfacing in VR
um I don't know how popular it's become
I must say when I've used it it's been
kind of not that exciting
um uh you know I kind of feel like there
are places where gesture-based
interfaces should be important like
shaping things in 3D and so on but I
don't think it's quite happened yet but
probably it will and that's something
where everybody's going to refer back to
Minority Report because that's the place
where people really saw you know these
kind of gesture-based interfaces
um being sort of put into practice I
think um you know voice controlled
computers well you know that was in Star
Trek that was in other things that there
was uh um there'd been they've been it
was obviously in 2001
um the um
uh yeah it's interesting question what
things have been in um uh
uh I don't know I'm I'm gonna show my
knowledge or lack thereof of popular
culture but you know the the kind of
bionic man type thing of of uh
um I I suspect many of those kinds of um
uh sort of Technology implanted
technology type Innovations uh those are
either here now or uh or are coming
that's another kind of uh directional
though although the kind of as I recall
that um that that character had the kind
of um uh you know the the just think
about focusing the the built-in you know
I we're not quite there yet with
artificial retinas and things but uh
probably will be
um you know I think they're uh oh gosh
what other things are there maybe
somebody can suggest some but um uh you
know sort of things from science fiction
I mean there's a there's plenty of of
things about the sort of social order
from science fiction which uh For Better
or Worse some of those have come to pass
um you know there's plenty of of
terrible dystopian uh expectations from
science fiction which you know some of
which
um are are strangely and disappointingly
uh coming to pass
um but uh you know in terms of
Technology I'm not sure
um
William was commenting the thing about
Chachi is it uses the same architecture
as gpt3 same number of parameters the
fact that fine tuning can create such a
leaping capability suggests we are in a
hardware overhang I'm not quite sure
what that means
um
it's uh
I don't quite know what that means I'd
like to know what that means actually
um
let's see cat is is asking has there
been any technology in history that's
been perfected like the wheel
um where
um
or is there always room for improvement
you know what tends to happen in
technology is is they get to some point
and then they kind of stabilize for
often a long time until some very
different thing comes along
I mean you know I'm always struck by
printer technology for example you know
there was a time when you were getting
new printers every every six months
because there were new things and so on
and then the printer that's sitting
under my desk I don't know how long it's
been there but but probably 10 years now
and it's it's you know it's it's a thing
where it got to a certain level of
capability and it uh it got good enough
that that's what you can get the there
wasn't a lot of there wasn't a lot of
ability to sort of engineer further you
know we see the same thing
um I don't know take CPU chips you know
they've been that's been sort of
progressive that was a kind of Moore's
Law uh kind of growth of speed of
computer CPU trips for a long time then
then some things kind of leveled off and
one had to have Innovations in other
places like multi-threading and gpus and
things like this I mean I kind of tend
to think that there's usually given a
sort of a big idea of some piece of
technology there's a point where it gets
to be
um uh sort of Fairly stable and and then
and then get sort of incremental
Improvement for a long time you talk
about Wheels I don't think it's true
that there's no innovation in Wheels I
mean I I've seen gosh probably even in
the last year I've seen Innovative
Wheels where they have different ways to
have uh you know different kinds of of
of of
um
sort of uh suspension mechanisms instead
of having tires and things different
kinds of axles
um you know different mechanisms for
being a wheel that can go over over a
complicated terrain there are there are
wheels that I think I've seen them for
for uh Rovers for planetary Rovers and
things different kinds of wheels so I
think even the wheel you know has
definitely not gotten to the point where
it's stabilized now you know I don't
know the paper clip or something that's
probably been the same for 100 and
something years but you know of course
there are different kinds of paper clips
and maybe there comes a time when
there's a very different thing you need
from your paper clip than and so then
there's sort of A disruption in that in
that area I mean I think um uh the um uh
you know I think the pattern and then
there are domains in which it's almost a
fashion statement that causes there to
be
sort of continued Innovation it's almost
you know independent of the raw
capability of the system it's like it's
it's differently dressed every year and
you know there are many Industries like
clothing for example where there is a
sort of driver of change that has
nothing to do with Technology Innovation
it's not that it's not you know there
have been new materials and so on and
new ways of manufacturing clothes but
hasn't changed that much what changes is
well one day there's a fashion for you
know this kind of this kind of you know
hoodie or whatever another time there's
a fashion for this kind of thing uh you
know waistcoats maybe we'll come back in
I don't know maybe they have a and I'm
I'm I haven't paid attention but but you
know there'll be these these these
drivers that are more a matter of the
kind of the um the herd of us humans
um saying oh that was a really cool
thing and you know I'm going to follow
that too then it is a matter of sort of
the driver of of innovation in the
actual core technology of what's going
on or even the supply chain of what's
going on on
um so I think I think that's some uh uh
yeah a few comments on that
um
memes is commenting
uh about printers the papers Jam 30
years ago papers paper jams today
yeah yeah I think paper Jam's got a bit
better but I don't know why that's I
don't know I I'm surprised that there
aren't ways of using modern sensor
technology and so on and modern control
systems and mems and all this kind of
thing to just you know banish paper jams
forever I mean it reminds me I was at
the Consumer Electronics Show a couple
few years ago and one of the tremendous
attractions giant line of people wanting
to see it was I think it was called I
think it was called the lawn Droid it
was a laundry folding robot
and it's something where that problem is
pretty hard of um of sort of the you
know the folding of thing with robotic
hands or whatever it turns out to be
pretty hard and probably eventually it
will get solved but it's it's uh you
know maybe the Paper Transport problem
is similarly hard
um
and uh uh spare parts is commenting
about the paper clip let's not ask the
AI to design a new type of paper clip
yeah there's a there's a famous kind of
uh story of um of the alignment of kind
of AI interests with human interests
which is you you tell the AI its goal is
make as many paper clips as possible and
then of course what it does eventually
is to to turn all humans and the world
into into pay-per-clip material which is
uh presumably a bad ending for us as
humans and um if there's a civilization
of the paper clips well that's a
different story
um
all right let's see uh
yeah William is commenting paper jams
happen today but paper has become
irrelevant yeah I mean it is true that a
single ream of paper that I put in my
printer seems to last me several years
now
um you know I really don't print very
much
um and uh you know I've noticed also
another another example of that is back
in the day people were like super I was
like I I you know when you traveled from
place to place it's like oh my gosh it's
going to take me this amount of time to
drive from here to there you know that's
terrible you know I I can't um uh you
know how am I going to you know it I'm
I'm burning I'm wasting an hour it's
terrible et cetera et cetera et cetera
and then there were cell phones and ever
since there have been cell phones it's
like well I've got calls I've wanted to
do and you know I set them up for when
I'm driving from here to there and I'm
like great this is this is all efficient
and you know it's same same with um uh
other kinds of you know there are
laptops I remember when I first had I
first had a a portable computer in
1981 maybe had an Osborne one sort of
suitcase sized computer that I I think I
may have been one of the first people to
take a computer through airport security
at Los Angeles at LAX airport
um it was kind of an interesting uh
interesting thing but um you know it was
a it was a computer that was not very
portable I remember the first actual
battery operated computer that I had was
a thing called the dg1 data General one
uh computer it must have been in
1985 perhaps
um that I am uh sort of proudly took on
a plane and was able to actually do
things you know truly on the go so to
speak but you know these things yes
these these things affect sort of the
importance of having the supersonic
plane and so on uh starts to seem a
little bit less when you realize oh I I
just get on a plane and I'm I'm you know
there's some cases where it might be
useful to get there quicker but it's
kind of like I'm gonna I'm gonna just
open up my computer I'm gonna start
working I have a different view than the
one I normally have but it's pretty much
the same same kind of story
um and uh yes I think I think that's
some
um that's uh
um you know that that does it's often
the wave I mean there's plenty of
technology that um uh we still have that
is very old and you know we still have
roads we still have um uh you know maybe
one day roads will become irrelevant
because flying you'll always fly from
here to there and nobody will care about
the roads so yes that could happen but
you know we're still at uh you know
we're a few thousand years and counting
on that particular technology and then
they're uh you know there are
technologies that um uh uh you know we
um uh that we sort of are close to us
humans and we're used to and so on that
I kind of think will be around for for a
while until until we have significant
changes in kind of the uh the character
of humans and so on
um
all right I think I should probably wrap
up uh well in a moment here let me see
maybe one more
question that might be um okay there's a
question here about physics from Zayden
about when and why was dark energy
hypothesized how dark energy okay I
thought I was reading that as dark
matter because the answer for dark
matter is it's 100 years it's people
looking at the rotation curves of
galaxies dark energy is much more recent
and has to do with people's estimate of
the expansion rate of the Universe I I
kind of think that both dark matter and
dark energy are probably not uh you know
that they're kind of Miss theories so to
speak in the sense that they are an
attempt to fit into current paradigms
for talking about things things that
really should be thought about in terms
of different paradigms it kind of
reminds me greatly of something I've
been studying a bunch recently which is
the history of the theory of heat and
where people believed well heaters are
fluid because fluids we understand what
fluids are they flow from here to there
heat can flow from here to there
Etc turns out heat isn't that he feet is
in a material for example is the motion
of molecules but that was just a
different paradigmatically different
kind of interpretation of what something
was than had existed and that's kind of
what I think is going to happen with
dark matter and dark energy but we shall
see
um uh William was commenting once we get
3D nanoreplicators we won't need roads
we'll just teleport from place to place
yeah I think that's a very interesting
thing of people talking about you know
you know how fast can we get from here
to there it's like well uh you know what
point you know if if the future of
humanity is a bunch of you know
disembodied Souls uploaded into some
digital system then the whole question
of Transportation becomes pretty moot
you know it's like well you're you're
kind of you know you're accessing a
different part of memory your your
electrons are going from here to there
maybe or you're just um you know it it's
no longer the uh the physical transport
of materials
um and and yes I think that that's I
mean there are many purposes for which
we could say right now uh you know to to
somebody from the past if we look at
your average you know video Zoom call or
something it's pretty much
um you know it's a it's it's a it's it's
something very close to kind of some
kind of teleportation in effect by the
way I mean that's a good example of this
sort of future prediction thing you know
in the 2001 movie there were video
phones and uh you know the idea of a
picture phone had existed from the 1950s
and I remember
I
first used a video phone
in
nineteen
see what must have been
it must have been around 1990
2.
and the way it worked was you you rented
it from the phone company and you rented
two of them and it you know over a phone
line it sent sent data and you got was
kind of slow but it worked
um and it is remarkable that everybody
knew video phones were coming everybody
knew that was going to happen but the
time scale and the and the manner in
which it arose was was really not quite
you know I I used to have the capability
to do video calls on computers starting
mid-1990s I didn't do it very much I did
it very little because I didn't find it
very useful and because it had enough
kind of detailed form factor issues that
wasn't wasn't attractive then then by
the when was it must have been by
guy I first did a um
a video talk at a conference
in I can work this out because it was
right when one of my yeah uh children
was born so uh 20 a bit more than a bit
more than 25 years ago so
um
the uh which is what um uh
1997-ish time frame
um that was that was when it first
became sort of feasible to do a kind of
video conference talk
um and without having very special uh
equipment at um uh well it was it was
still special equipment at that time I
then briefly tried sending a a
telepresence robot around as my proxy to
various kinds of events that was amusing
while it lasted it wasn't very practical
um it's kind of been that that's a
technology where I kind of feel like one
day maybe that will be a technology that
will kind of come in and one will be um
uh you know that will be a routine thing
to do but it hasn't happened yet I mean
I I kind of thought you know for a while
that the kind of the virtual oh I really
want to go you know see Machu Picchu for
example but I don't want to go and you
know
go to all the way to Peru and high
altitude and all this kind of thing I'm
just going to send my drone there and
I'm going to do a kind of personalized
tour where I can just be droning around
or roboting around it it seemed like
that was going to come in but it didn't
actually happen uh maybe it will in the
in the future
um I think uh maybe that will come in
maybe maybe that's what's going to come
in maybe that's one of the use cases for
uh Moon exploration maybe the um uh you
know very very few of us in the in the
foreseeable future will end up going to
the Moon just as very few of us go to
Antarctica are probably even less I
don't know less to the moon or not it
seems that it's maybe it's cooler in
some sense to go to the Moon than to go
to Antarctica so more people will do it
but um uh maybe the thing that will
happen is that there'll be a uh a big
you know well you don't get to go
yourself but you can be the you know you
can control this this Rover or this
drone that's that's uh how would a drone
work on the moon good question I the you
know with the Mars helicopter we know
that it's possible to have um a
drone-like flight on Mars even though it
has a thin atmosphere and you know the
helicopter blades got the speed of sound
and all that kind of cool stuff
um on on the moon I think uh
um it's kind of like well actually 2001
had a moon bus so um uh which presumably
worked with rockets
um but uh uh yeah that's a that's a bit
of a different technology
um than um probably takes more more
energy but I I don't know how um I don't
know quite how that would work but but
um at least a robot wandering around on
the moon that might be the the moon
tourism that might be the ticket for
Moon tourism so to speak that um uh you
know you pretty pretty soon you find um
the Moon is covered with uh random uh
robot tourists so to speak I don't know
quite what the speed of light delay
associated with um you know the one
second speed of light delay associated
with getting signal to the Moon I'm not
sure quite how that would affect you
know Luna virtual tourism but um uh oh
yes somebody's commenting here about the
communication latency to the Moon right
um
well it's much worse for Mars doing
doing that with a 20-minute
um you know uh latency that's a that's a
funky thing you'd have to have um I
don't really think that's going to work
to Mars to do uh you know uh Martian
tourism but you know I I mean
it uh it's just one of those things
which maybe one day it'll be all the
rage but um it hasn't it hasn't happened
yet and that might be a feature of
Technology it might just be a feature of
of uh you know human Fashions and so on
um I suppose it's uh
um uh it seems like well yeah the
all right well let's see we should
probably wrap up here and um
uh
I think um
uh lots of interesting questions I thank
you for that and I think there were a
few at the beginning that I absolutely
didn't get to so apologies about that
and and um uh
maybe um
next time
well thanks for joining me and uh see
you another time
bye for now